i have a terrible facial hair problem
while the professors in harry potter may
have a wand up there you know what the
actors themselves love pulling pranks
and laughing on set i remember it was
called the one broomstick
number one disrespecting professor
umbridge is something we can get behind
while we can't tell you why this deleted
scene of professor trelawny exists we
are just so glad that it does the theory
is they were just doing a long pan shot
of all the professors and emma thompson
was improvising and being so ridiculous
they paused and focused on
that her to be
prolimited seriously we could just sit
here and watch this for another minute
or two maybe an hour or how about the
entirety of harry potter told through
professor trelawny's eyes thank you
professor umbridge but it really was
still illuminating number two the
internet will never let daniel radcliffe
forget this one michael gambin and alan
rickman hold the best prank on dan
really really funny and for you while
he's supposed to be silently sleeping in
a room full of other young wizards the
mayhem began in our dreams
we enter completely our own world
the best part was dan has us to have his
sleeping bag next to this particular
girl that he fancy it was alan rickman
who planted the fart machine and we like
to we like to swim
in the deepest waters but it was michael
who was pressing the button
michael and alan were good buddies on
set michael was always making alan laugh
and they were lucky if they got a take
where he didn't crack so you are ce
number three we would take maggie smith
as our dance partner any day of the week
this leg moves first maggie in character
teaching rupert grint to dance while
she's hanging out in her robe is just
hilarious put your hand on my your right
hand on my waist it's probably good
we've got visuals to describe the scene
otherwise you might have thought
something else no you will have to lead
eventually her metaphors are the perfect
cocktail of elegance and quirkiness
inside every boy a lordly lion prepared
to prance and rupert grint was just a
wee bit embarrassed of the whole
situation telling onlookers that no one
is to breathe a word about the moment
never gonna let him forget this are you
never
number four magic meets technology
alan rickman whacked his hand off the
camera and only had this anticlimactic
thing to say
and yet it's still hilarious he's not
one to break character too much unless
michael gambon's around but odds are
this footage wasn't salvageable anyways
number five a thousand takes would make
for a long day robbie coltrane's
responses to literally everything are
just hilarious
one thousand take one
was that a thousand
we're hey
robbie we're not sure a thousand takes
is necessarily a good thing we do our
best to do it number six if only ron
were as talented with a wand as he is
with a quill rupert grint was caught
doodling a nasty image of alan rickman
alan rickman was standing right behind
me and i was so scared life imitates art
sometimes
if you're playing the quote unquote evil
dark arts teacher you should just expect
some sassy students the picture wasn't
nice either it was uh yeah i think i
exaggerated a few of his features
well alan rickman like the true
gentleman he is kept rupert's art i've
made him sign it and i have it in my
possession
and i'm very fond of it number seven now
for the hero of our generation when
filch's cat is petrified in the movie
kenneth branagh's character said ah
thought so so unlucky i wasn't there
i know exactly the counter curse that
could have spared her but we found
another improvised take it was
definitely a curse that killed her
probably the transmcgriffian torture
encountered it myself once
number eight or richard was too gentle
for this world richard harris thought
the animatronic of fox the phoenix was
real and so when no one else was in the
room he was interacting with the bird
and the sneaky tech people were
puppeting said animatronic from outside
of the room to let him believe in the
magic nobody ever told him the bird was
fake and we think it's just better that
way pretty good huh number nine children
are a nuisance while professor
mcgonagall would never threaten to hurt
a student we never use transfiguration
as a punishment maggie smith might not
be so strict with herself like how about
this moment she pretends she's going to
thump one of the kids with a scroll yes
yes we know it's all teasing number 10.
robbie coltrane goofing about in the
motorcycle makes everyone on set burst
out into giggles including dan
[Music]
this lovable goof can probably make even
the grumpiest of people laugh on a bad
day number 11 and our least favorite
professor is full of personality while
professor umbridge is evil in the movie
behind the scenes imelda staunton and
mcgonagall were best buds imelda sings
oh
just
yes
and she blah blah blah is about
disloyalty
number 12 we still find it hard to
believe hogwarts hosts a rave did you
know professor flitwick crowdsurfing at
the ewo ball was only meant to be a joke
it's true i said wouldn't it be funny if
flipwick did a stage dive the director
went away for the weekend and warwick
davis couldn't believe his ears he said
we're gonna do that and so i was only
joking here's hoping he enjoyed himself
and maybe ticked something off the
bucket list number 13 never let go filch
put your hands with me
david bradley wasn't meant to hang on to
tom felton forever but he just wasn't
ready to let go even while the cameras
weren't rolling but hey maybe he had a
perfect grip and just didn't want to
lose it number 14. what is it with harry
potter and gas he was a little boy
obviously in the first one and he said
he was really traumatized by her miriam
margulies hasn't bothered to watch most
of the harry potter movies well i've
only been to the one ones i'm in and i
fall asleep if you remember professor
sprout with the screaming plants she's
not happy about her time on harry potter
or rather not happy she wasn't in all of
them that was a brave oversight i'm
holding you responsible miriam
traumatized daniel radcliffe when he was
a wee boy she's quite the character
which you'd know if you've ever seen her
on a talk show ages but a number and
she's hilarious i've been told there was
a swear jar involved on set well a young
dan didn't appreciate her behavior with
the cursing i was probably careful when
it was you but when you know with the
other kids i didn't bother
that wasn't the worst part though it was
the farting that really got to him i'm
very proud of it number fifteen it
doesn't take michael gammon a
transformation spell to alter his
performance michael's a bit of a
goofball when we do the scene now again
in a minute i should change my mind this
cracks up radcliffe in a completely
different way michael we applaud your
nuance the cast of harry potter still
leaves us laughing even all these years
later do you ever wish you could go back
in time and experience it again for the
first time let us know in the comments
and thanks for hanging out with us here
at the things